you got started on the radio is that
correct that is yes in in England you
were on the radio I I was what kind of
show was this it's it's called The
Archers and um it's been going for 50
years uh it started in I can't even work
it's too much for me to work out what 50
years from 2014 is so I won't try and do
that but yeah it was 1963 really you're
good you're good no I'm
[Applause]
was like I can I can look real smart
here for a second what could it be I
know exactly what it is yeah um I'm
kidding I'm
28 you're looking good than great thank
you I look terrible for
28 uh so uh so you were saying you were
on a a a show a radio show what kind of
radio what's the radio show about was it
a soap opera it's a soap opera and it's
about farming um and I I played a a pig
farmer's daughter called Emma Grandy
you're lying there's no there's a soap
opera about farmers in England yes and
you played the pig farmer's daughter
named she was she was called Emma Carter
uhhuh okay um and she would also help
not only with the pigs but my father in
in the show also had sheep um this is
exciting
and it's a riveting show really so this
is and it's a show that's been around a
long time and it does it dispense I mean
it just takes place it's a soap oper
that takes place on a farm yeah well it
started in the it started in the 50s it
was supposed to be about sort of
agricultural information for the country
and then now it's become a drama and
they're like screw that let's make it a
a soap op and get people listening so
when you're on radio you have to your
acting style has to be completely
different right it does yes I mean it's
all it's obviously just all about your
voice right and sound effects and things
like I I'm going to cross the room now
and then you do that or no yeah well
actually someone else does the walking
uhhuh so there's a the person who does
all the sound effects so they so if you
have to walk then they'll do the tread
and then there's the with if you're
doing there's a lot of sheep birthing as
it's a farming program um that's soap
opera now I have to hear this soap opera
it's like tune in next week another
sheep birth yeah it's what we like in
England what sound effects are there for
a sheep birth uh a yogurt what a yogurt
and a spoon oh my God yeah a guy's just
there mixing yogurt and a spoon and
going absolutely you've got it and then
you're sort of going as he's making the
sound you're you're watching and you're
going I hope I hope the Lamb's going to
be okay and then he's like squelching
the yogurt as a oh my
God I am obsessed now I have to hear
this show uh let's talk about the
invisible woman uh this is uh based on
real history yes you uh you play a young
woman who had a secret affair with
Charles Dickens Char
Dickens unhappily married we can say uh
which i' actually actually knew about
and you play someone who has an affair
yes with the great Charles Dickens
indeed yes it was she was um 18 and he
was 45 at the time and they were very
deeply in love with each other but it
was a it was a very complicated
relationship right uh let's take a look
at this clip from The Invisible
Woman n it was a mistake did you send
Catherine to
me yes she is the mother of your
children how could you be so cruel to
her for that I shall always be grateful
but I do not love
her she comprehends nothing she sees
nothing I thought if she saw you then
she would understand that I have nothing
with
her I wanted her to see it
it what is it
Charles what is it that we
are when your wife are asked me if I if
I was fond of
you I could not honestly
reply I wanted to say
no